.
AN HAS MORE.  P
>> THIT TOWN O
PLATHATD HERE.
E  S 280 MOMPANY HASTH
SATELLITES IN ORBIT THAT NE,
DISPLAYED IN ITSADQUAR CANINOUT
AT DETAIL,
SATEOF A CERMARI TD
USION FORD UNIVERSITRTT OFDOOUW
>> YOU
HAT SHOW A
HERE IESDIRTEY'VE BE UULLDOZERIY
>> IMAGES URTHD I Y EYY FOR
HIDINBUTELLITE F TANKS NG THROY
VEHICLES
.
THEYNTO TH
SOIL
TNC HERE.ND THEN EROTHER ASCTTR
ON
LTSOMETHING THAT'S VERY HARD TUH
E GRM IT
THIS IS A O,U RAINIS VERY
AGRICULTURAL COUSE
DAAT. HAPPENE?
RE IPPED HERE.N E AS
E FOILOSND EXPLODED
WEORAGE
T OF LTH Y SEED OUT.
TOORISIS ISDZ ON .
'R FEES EFFE
REVERBERG ER THEAR Reporte PLAS
E S. GOVERNMENT,
MANY OTHER GOVERNMENTSAN
E NO DOUBT
ITS BORDERS ND
HUMANITARIAN ETSUCE O ESSTT.
>> Reporter: RETURNING BACK TO
ITIVE TO CURRENTUPOL
SH